[Musique]
un écrivain jean paul clébert a mis en
bonne place dans son ouvrage provence
insolite l'image d'un spécialiste dont
je vais vous montrer le travail
nous sommes à saint christol d'albion en
vaucluse monsieur kléber homonyme de
l'écrivain prépare une expérience
délicate mais non mais non il ne s'agit
pas d'un documentaire
voilà il suffit de rassembler les
abeilles prenez la reine enfermés là
dans une petite boîte que vous fixé à
votre cou
[Musique]
à
et
les abeilles n'attaque pas monsieur
kléber il doit insister pour être piqué
[Musique]
il
encourageant les abeilles
[Musique]
et les abeilles monte monte la fidélité
à leur reine les guides peut être aussi
leur amitié pour monsieur kléber
affectueusement vôtre
et voilà une belle barbe d'abeilles vous
connaissez maintenant la recette essayé
mais songez aux malheurs des barbus
[Musique]